d'accord allait elle est un peu nos
chris marquès et jean marc généreux du
jour
est-ce qu'on va danser avec les hmam et
je rappeler le premier couple c'est
parti vite un partenaire christine kelly
[Applaudissements]
aïe
je gare aux jeunes
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attendez allez y à rien le voilà alors
là le micro de christine qui dit vous
allez mettre des notes colline colline
vous mettez convainc 5,5
c'est pas mal et tendent à 105,5
pourquoi alors j'aurai mieux
en fait j'ai mis sept pour l'engagement
mais il ya vraiment un engagement sans
qu'ils ont envie de bien jouer et après
samba côté il y avait c'était pas
tellement ensemble mais voilà s'il a
brillé il ya eu un effort
bravo et vous le catogan vous va très
bien vous pouvez vous m tu peux parler à
déchirer puisqu'on va accueillir tout de
suite le deuxième couple de ce soir
c'est parti bouillant quand je
m'inquiète albiez sa partenaire pradélie
bénin
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
voilà
cb la line dance à gauche mais là il va
pas faire des boulettes papauté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le porc
douchez vous mettez le hashtag des ael
rage donc dalle dalle jetable à la voile
a acheté à l h pour donner une note bien
sûr à chaque couple pour l'instant vous
vous avez une moyenne de 5,1 gilles et
kestelyn vous c'était vraiment un jeu
mais n'avait pas influencé mais j'ai
trouvé que c'était une mer de sang nous
je le dis benhaim catastrophique mais là
où sur la tête de ma mère elle faisait
rien c'est à dire mais on dirait qu'elle
attendait là de la cuisson des boulettes
[Applaudissements]
les notes colline
si ce n'est leur colis non je peux pas
te laisser versa si elle avait eu
l'audace mais pas être aussi généreux 4
pourquoi parce que en fait j rey code
pour benjamin mais franchement il
manquait d'engagement de tabac ouais
mais tu as vu le partenaire médaille
mais ça manquait d'engagement à les
rejoindre vos petits camarades
[Applaudissements]
elle assure bien sûr pour donner une
note les chéris au couple et ce
troisième couple c'est mon couple favori
je vous le dis tout de suite c'est celui
est favori pour moi ce soir ils ont
gagné un concours à guingamp encore la
semaine dernière voici le troisième
couple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous
ah ouais
d'abord et sa page
oh la la
à
ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et je suis tranquille y aura cinq
couples ce soir il y aura cinq couples
et loire il a d'autres et c'était
beaucoup plus favori mais les gens
pensent souvent venu se tromper et
sachez le des ael h
le couple gagnant je vous jure c'est
vrai viendra faire un tango dans votre
salon non mais je vous dis pendant une
demi-heure et mêlera danse et anboto
salon chez vous où que vous soyez voilà
si vous avez le contrôle obligatoire
vous aurez donc sonné olivier ont battu
mais cette polémique
moi j'ai trouvé ça merveilleux ambitieux
impérieux du territoire qui nous fait
8000 moyenne c'est notre coupe pour
l'instant pour les membres du jury
notre groupe favori mais yamaha les
votes du public et chez vous bien sûr
des ael h danse avec la mort attention
le quatrième couple au départ j'étais
pas pour c'est un couple ken grande
différence d'âge mais qui néanmoins
c'est danser ensemble ils s'aiment en
secret il est blond il est grand il est
con elle est belle elle est belle et
elle amena pas d'un quota voici notre
quatrième couple ses bas congo interdits
aux moins de 18 ans matthieu delormeau
et sa partenaire
isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de france amateur
vous
[Musique]
[Rires]
il a du bon elle est fière de la crise
pendant que la cinquantaine d'années
sans rigoler mais c'est ouf ça a été
battu et j'ai perdu un [ __ ] évacués
on va les retrouver c'est comment
appelle-t-on go à mykonos comment le
tango à mykonos ses gonds s'appelle nom
de tanguay oh la la c'est comment on
appelle quelqu'un qui fait une mauvaise
manie si un bon emploi
quelqu'un qui rentre chez lui et ce
alors c'était pas mal alors à quand des
vestiaires avec la pologne
mathieu isabelle nordmann alors collines
comme hatem 8 a cogné quatre coups
et toi maintenant 11 mai 18 pour les
pompiers quel outarka les paddocks
passante mais combien quoi il faut une
vraie nos brême dans le nord une vraie
note web 1 8 me et enfin le dernier
coupe c'est le couple le plus jeune ou
ça fait des semaines et des semaines
qu'on a envie que d'une chose c'est
qu'il se pécho il arrive à conclure
est-ce que ce tango va les rapprocher ou
peut-être que ce tango ce sera le
dernier tango c'est fort ça et c'est pas
écrit ça je voulais dire benhaim à
présent de la graine castaldi avait rien
alors présent de la graine à quesques à
ça de l'or monte aussi on vous parle un
peu français
[Rires]
attaque de la mer 24 à 10 on dirait une
tribu dans terre inconnue non mais
sérieux j'adore mais j'adore moi j'adore
ça va vous sinon très bien je sais pas
si ça vous va ou pas ça les deux mondes
les faits en tout cas moi non en vrai je
vous revois c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être trouvé votre style non je suis
pas sûr si moi je vous trouve très beau
comme ça voilà d'ailleurs sa femme
adorée
c'est vrai la même appelé pour lui dire
ce soir vient avec cette coiffure on
aura on fera un tiramisu et panna cotta
nord bassora
merci oui qu'à saluer ce soir est
toujours marié à l'est le dernier couple
c'est parti j'ai alors attendu interdits
aux moins de 18 ans matthieu delormeau
et sa partenaire
isabelle morini bosc
ressortez et c'est pas possible c'est
maintenant de la danse à l'aller kelly
calme toi allez merci on y va c'est
reparti alors vous vous allez faire une
entrée comme ça parce qu'on vous a pas
rentrer dans l'ordinateur pour un tango
interdits aux moins de 18 ans matthieu
delormeau et sympa mais ne mettait pas
les terriens bercy a désigné sérieux ah
oui
à paris
ah ouais quand même ah ils ont bossé
ils sont votés
ces sauvages
taillon se bouffer
ah non ça pouf et away
voilà c'est bien
ah oui voilà
ah ouais
[Musique]
pas juste ça mais nous savions que
maintenant c'est trois parades
[Musique]
je laisse ça à bosser dans son combat et
bien moi je vois qu'il ya beaucoup de
travail à faire et chorégraphies ouais
après ça manquait un peu de style entre
eux mais en off
mettez vous l'avez tous les trucs nous
aligner les chéris on va découvrir tout
de suite votre classement je voudrais
qu'on découvre un par un les coupes du
dernier au premier d'accord en régie si
c'est possible et dernier est ce que
c'est possible aux messages que vous
pouvez nous parler des années seront les
premiers et banamba c'est comme ça vous
vous démerdez vous me le dit alors les
cherry on va demander de raconter une
vanne en attendant donc je vais tout
simplement faire le bilan je veux dire
moi tous les gens dépensent et ça ça
pourri pourri pourri ça pas mal
dégueulasse non dégueulasse et sa chef
médard cas je mets la famille mes
préférés ce succès vous moi je vous dis
pour une question de jacques physique je
vous trouve ça allait très bien ensemble
six mois ferme et sans rigoler c'est
vrai vous avez vous fait un beau couple
ça rigolait serey die rythme annuel et
brigitte on va voir qui a gagné le dance
est clair mal parce qu'ils iront ils
diront je dis bien les grands gagnants
dans séché une personne pendant toute la
soirée vers le congo dans le salon baby
n'est pas récent mais tous franchi le
dernier coup à wisches et à ma chérie
affiche moi j'ai lu christine égale 5
donc ces derniers coupons ingénue
christine merci par comprend rien à ce
qu'ils font mais ils se débrouillent du
le monde quatre numéros 4 ne marche pas
numéro justement à l'oreille redémarrer
il ya tout le monde à 5
d'accord tout peut apparemment vous êtes
dernier d'accord alors avant dernier non
c'est un saint claude et jean michel et
jacques l les nantis vieux ça alors
attention et à gagner jean-michel
motivés passionnés
vous irez danse et vous irez danser les
chéris vous irez donc danser chez une
personne voilà je vous le dis